so in my last video i did a uh reaction
to a quote by sam harris that we saw in
an interview looking at what exactly is
heaven in the christian christian
conception
and to be honest you know i didn't only
do it as a reaction to sam i did it
because i noticed that
a lot of christians were confused about
what that was and a lot of christians
have a very
literalistic or materialist
only materialist version of what it is
that heaven is in scripture and so
um in the last video i use dante and i
use heidegger and a few other examples
and on social media i've quoted from the
church fathers but i thought it would be
a good idea to go straight into
scripture and to look at the words of
christ himself and how what he seems to
be talking about when he mentions heaven
and so we're going to look at uh the uh
the story of the two tenets which was la
yesterday was sunday's gospel reading
during in the orthodox church and we'll
see how it helps us understand what
heaven is
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Applause]
[Music]
so the parable of the two tenets is in
matthew 18.
and so i will read the text for you and
we'll look at how it helps us understand
what it is that heaven is and what it's
referring to
and so it starts in chapter in verse 23
it says therefore the kingdom of heaven
is like a king
who wanted to settle accounts with his
servants as he began the settlement a
man who owed him ten thousand bags of
gold was brought to him
since he was not able to pay the master
ordered that he and his wife and his
children and all that he had be sold to
repay the debt
at this the servant fell on his knees
before him be patient with me he begged
and i will pay everything back the
servant's master took pity on him
canceled the debt and let him go
but when that servant went out he found
one of his fellow servants who owed him
a hundred silver coins
he grabbed him and began to choke him
pay back what you owe me he demanded
his fellow servant fell to his knees and
begged him be patient with me and i will
pay it back but he refused instead he
went off and had the man thrown in
prison until he could pay the debt
when the other servants saw what had
happened
they were outraged and went and told
their master everything that had
happened then the master called the
servant in you wicked servant he said i
cancelled all that debt of yours because
you begged me to
should you have had mercy on your fellow
servants just as i had on you
in anger his master handed him over to
the jailers to be tortured until he
should pay back all he owed
this is how my heavenly father will
treat each of you unless you forgive
your brother and sister from your heart
so the first thing to notice is that
there's a different there are a few
layers of meaning that are brought
together a few analogies to help you
understand
what it is that heaven is and what is
the kingdom of heaven and so
the first thing that is mentioned is of
course a king because the kingdom is
related to a king therefore a king is a
good image understand what it is that
heaven is that is what it is that is
above you in terms of a hierarchy a
hierarchy of relationship a hierarchy of
causality as well here we're not talking
so much about a hierarchy
of causality directly but something like
uh
a hierarchy that that let's say let's
the
lets the level underneath it exists
without being completely subservient to
it you know at the top
giving a certain amount of freedom for
lower levels of a hierarchy to exist so
there's there's this hierarchy and the
and the servant owes the king
amounts of money that are what is 10 000
talents in the original text something
like millions and millions and millions
of dollars something that he could never
pay back
and so his existence is his existence is
dependent
on the king his dependence on the mercy
of the king and the king offers the
mercy despite that he owes everything to
heaven that he owes everything to to
that which is above him the king lets
the lower level of the hierarchy exist
uh you know through a kind of grace you
could say by letting it exist on its own
without being so dependent on the higher
levels of the hierarchy that they are
complete slaves and completely you know
imprisoned by a tyranny of authority you
could say and so it is first of all a
beautiful example of the manner in which
god
lets us exist or
how god created the world in a way that
is not just a bunch of robots that are
there to serve god but that there really
is this sense in which the way
christians understand creation we
understand that every level of this
hierarchy of beings this hierarchy of of
relationships has its own existence to a
certain extent and is not completely
is not com is not in an illusion or is
not completely dependent from the levels
above him
and so you can understand that so you
can see that the manner in which the
kingdom of heaven is described is as the
relationship in a hierarchy between that
which is above and that which is below
and so when when
people tell me that that this is some
kind of superfluous interpretation that
uh that this song that comes later it's
something that we superimpose on a bunch
of materialists who think that heaven is
just the dome in the sky and that jesus
is sitting you know above on on clouds
and he's going to come down and it's
completely this materialist
interpretation
you can see that this is
this is already discounted in scripture
itself it's already discounted in the
the words of christ who describes
the kingdom of heaven as a relationship
hierarchical relationship of different
causality now in other places in
scripture he'll describe it in different
ways but it will always come back to
something like this the relationship of
a seed to the fruits or relationship of
the the heaven to the earth in terms of
a hierarchy a procession of authority or
a procession of grace or whatever it is
the manner in which it's described it is
described as a relationship of that
which is above very much in the way that
we understand a boss today or something
that we describe metaphorically as being
above this is also the manner in which
christ understands heaven and so he is
of course giving in an allegory he's
giving a a story to help you understand
the relationship of god to creation and
what's interesting about
this is that the manner in which christ
describes the relationship between
that which is above and that which is
below is actually the notion of a
pattern to be embodied that is that what
we receive from heaven
we have to embody it ourselves in the
world that is the the grace that we
receive from heaven
is has to be embodied in the world or
else it it loses its reality it is not a
kingdom of heaven it is not the rule of
heaven over the earth and so the the
image of the king which
the example that the king gives or that
which the king gives is completely
a complete other level
of value to that which the servant is
able to then give
horizontally let's say to the other
servants in the house and so this is a
way to help you understand actually a
difference in quality which is very hard
to capture in a parable it's hard to
capture in general the difference of
quality but here it's it's represented
as an amount so much that it actually
would be completely impossible for any
normal person for any person to pay that
back so he owes so much that he could
never pay it back that's a it's a kind
of apophatic way or a kind of negative
way to help you understand that we're
dealing with another level of grace
another level of relationship
between the servant and the king to then
the servant with the other servants at
the same level that he is and so the the
kingdom of heaven
is when that which we receive from above
is now reproduced on the horizontal
level that is you have to embody the
pattern which comes from above and that
is how you are a participant in heaven
that's how you receive the kingdom of
heaven and so there's nothing arbitrary
about the way it's described it is
completely coherent
in terms of
what it is that heaven is and then what
happens is that if you do not embody the
pattern
from heaven
the higher patterns then you will be
you could say you will be you will be
cut off you will be tortured you will
the pattern of heaven that which is
above you will appear like a judge it
will appear like a judge because it is
an ideal that you're not embodying
though you should and now the ideal
appears is something which pains you
which makes you suffer so you can
understand that of course
people will get annoyed because it
it sounds all cruel and god is cruel but
this is something that you can
experience all the time which is that if
you want you know sorry i'm using a lot
of sports analogies these these days but
it's a good way to understand it that is
if you have an ideal in playing a sport
and you you that idea let's say would be
the reason why you're in this sport in
the first place
but you are completely incapable of
embodying it in the world then that
ideal to the extent that you remain
within that sport is going to make you
suffer you're going to suffer basketball
you're going to suffer football because
you're not able to embody
that pattern or you're not willing or
you're not willing to practice or
whatever it is you're doing say you're
not willing to practice and because you
don't practice then you then you you
can't really play very well so what's
going to happen if you stay in that
sport is that you're going to be you're
going to be captured by it you're going
to be tortured by it until you're able
to
to pay it off until you're able to
justify your connection to the sport and
so maybe if you're on a team you're
gonna you're gonna stay on the bench the
whole time and and in other types of
images that christ uses maybe you'll be
cut off that you'll be thrown out of the
team you know because you're not able to
you'll be judged and thrown out by the
team because you're not able to
be in the kingdom of basketball you're
not able to be able to participate in
the kingdom of whatever it is pattern
that you're trying to to to focus on to
concentrate to concentrate on or to to
embody and so
what's important to understand as well
is that it really is
you know it's not just a bunch of
it's not only also only a question of
ethics it's not just a question of
morality it is a question of
it is a question of that which makes you
exist
at the level you exist and that you
embodying it
is what is continuing to make that world
exist and so this idea that you owe
something to god is a good image to help
you understand it's like you you
actually
your connection to that which is above
is a connection of existence
and and if you don't embody it properly
then you're going to suffer in that
existence and you can understand it
again like if you think about a sport
it's not about just the rules of the
sport like you can know all the rules
and you could even follow the rules of
the sport but that doesn't mean you're
going to embody the spirit of the sport
you're playing that you're going to
embody it at a horizontal level that has
more to do with a kind of practice a
kind of
you know a kind of engagement you know
dedication and and also just a a a focus
and an energy that you put into
something and it's different than the
notion of ethics or doing
ethics in the way the weird way that we
talk about morality today
um
or even the idea that we think about in
terms of rules it really is more more
has more to do with allegiance to the
pattern
that which gives the pattern above and
then manifested in the world and one of
the things also
that is shown here
is that these types of patterns
they actually don't appear so much as
abstract
things and so sometimes i represent them
as abstract things to help you
understand because
the truth is most of these
types of patterns are personal they
appear as personal
examples that are then embodied in the
world and so you can see it like you can
imagine
let's let's use an image of uh
of basketball again
and so
so the sport of basketball is started by
people who have given the examples and
the rules of the game like there are
many games that have been invented in
the world there's thousands of other
games why is it that basketball
is particularly interesting is that
there have been in the sport figures
that have
shown that really were shining and
there's something about the embodiment
of the sport which manifests a grace
which manifests something that people
are attracted to and find valuable so in
the world of basketball think of someone
like michael jordan and so
you can imagine that
someone like michael jordan in the world
of basketball has done something like
ascend into heaven
and so he has reached a level of
principality and so it's not just that
he's a good player it's that he has
become
an example in ways that actually make
the sport more and so michael jordan has
raised the level of what is possible in
basketball and has therefore established
a path
and an example for people to follow in
order to embody more basketball and so
before michael jordan certain
moves certain ways of playing certain
things weren't possible they just
weren't on the horizon of possibility
for people but now that someone has
risen up into heaven as has risen up in
excellency in a manner that is so high
then that becomes like a becomes an
example a point of light that others can
now follow and so you can see in that
world that the game of basketball was
transformed and elevated because someone
went up into heaven of basketball you
could say and this is true of a lot of
sports for example you know if you
you've probably heard the story of how
you know people used to say that a four
minute mile was impossible that nobody
could ever run a four-minute mile but
then as soon as someone elevates
themselves and reaches that
impossibility you could say then they
something like ascend into heaven and
now all of a sudden they open the door
for those behind them and now all these
people very quickly will be able to
manifest that which was manifested by
that that pioneer that first person and
this is true of many many fields many
many examples but it can help you to
understand you know what it is that
we're talking about when we're talking
about heaven of course i'm not talking
about basketball i'm talking about in
general the notion of the relationship
between principalities the relationship
between that which gives the example or
that which reigns over a certain amount
of of
of reality in the world and of course in
the case of god that is all things in
the crease of christ of course we also
believe that he has gathered all of this
into himself like you can see in um
in saint paul at some point he talks
about how christ is at this moment you
know you know
ascending the hierarchy and and
dominating over all these principalities
and and thrones and whatever and so the
idea is that that that he is you know
invisibly becoming the head of something
so you don't see the fruits yet and and
you know you can think that paul was
just imagining things but after a few
hundred years when rome completely
converted and you know huge amounts of
the the pop the the world converted and
it's contin still happening people are
still you know in africa and asia there
are still mass convergence there are
these huge movements towards
christianity that you could say that
christ is ascending still ascending you
could say in a in a secret way ascending
the hierarchies of principalities and
still subjugating different
principalities to himself uh and so that
might sound like magic but if you
understand it then you can understand a
lot about how the world lays itself out
it makes it can make sense of a lot of
things and that actually you know even
our countries our our families we don't
base ourselves on ideals we base
ourselves on examples you can put up all
the rules you want for your family you
can decide your family is going to do
this and that but if you don't if as a
parent you don't lead by example
it's just not going to happen
it kids look at people as examples and
it's the same a country is not based on
abstract principles countries are based
on founders countries are based on
people who have left stories behind them
who have left institutions behind them
who have you know pioneered and we
follow that is actually
how the world works and as we try to
move towards abstraction
as you know
as that which leads us or that which
which constitutes reality then then we
will watch things fragment more and more
and if we try to destroy the story of
our origins and destroy the the story of
our leaders then we will find ourselves
in scattered and in despair this is
inevitable and so hopefully this was
just another little example to help you
show that when we talk about heaven as a
hierarchy of causalities a hierarchy of
of relationships let's say uh that this
is not something that we're making up or
even something that you find only later
in dante that like i was quoting but
it's something that is there already in
scripture because when christ talks
about the relationship between the what
god does and the fruits that we
manifested in the world that is just how
hierarchies that's just how hierarchies
work you know if you're in an army if
you're in the army and the you know the
commander gives
sends down a command hopefully leads by
example if he's a general especially the
old style generals like if you think of
alexander who would lead by example into
battle and then would would expect his
men to follow him be behind him and if
they didn't then then they would
they would not be in the kingdom of
alexander they would be in trouble they
would be
you know under judgment you could say
and there's a million millions examples
of of of things like that some of them
can actually be negative like they could
be you could be in a
in a you could follow something a false
hierarchy right that's why
you see in scripture you know the the
devil is is called the prince of the air
or you see that in different traditions
the notion you know the the king of this
world and so there are there's also
false versions of this false hierarchies
you know twisted hierarchies as well but
even though they're twisted and false if
you even you looked at at how twisted
there i can still help you understand
what it is that we're talking about
we're just not talk when we say that
that you know the devil is the prince of
the heir or you know the
the king of this world we're not talking
of we're not talking about the fact that
he floats around in the sky or that he
sits
on a
throne though those images are perfectly
acceptable analogically to help us
understand what it is that we're talking
about and so uh thank you for your
attention hopefully this was helpful uh
thanks again everybody for supporting
what i'm doing i really appreciate it i
know things are getting wilder and
wilder out there and that it's also
becoming more difficult financially and
so to all of you that have continued to
support my work i truly appreciate it
and
and hopefully we'll continue on from
today so talk to you very soon